first question because you've worked
with a couple of the major Animation
Studios at this point what do you think
a shared quality they have that allows
you to deliver your best work but then
also I want something specific to
DreamWorks that you really appreciate
well I you know we were just at the NFC
uh Film Festival which is an Animation
Festival in France and it is an
incredible experience to see the amount
of students worldwide in animation
um and so you know any studio right now
around the world there's so much talent
there's so much energy and so much
there's so much imagination that these
young boys are bringing into animation
which is just exciting to be around
um so I think that everyone's sharing in
that we're all sharing the Boon of you
know how much people love animation
um and how much great education there is
in students
um but for DreamWorks I find one thing
really particularly wonderful I'm
working on this film was our design
Department Pierre Olivia Vincent our
production designer who did all the How
to Train Your Dragons the way that
DreamWorks can render and bend
believability and build worlds and the
effects uh that I think is really this
the team that I've worked with or as
Dave wolver Pierre Olivia Vincent Carlos
Portola you know that ability I say to
bend believability and also to give that
level of sophistication but at the same
time super appealing makes this movie
from a four-year-old niece and for me
also speaking of how much talent there
is in the animation sphere right now I
wanted to ask you about the choice two
or to not have a co-director because
you've worked both ways so what signals
to you that a story a production
requires a co-director and then
ultimately y was fair and the perfect
pick for that role yeah no well we I was
very lucky because when I came onto the
movie farron was already the head of
story
and I'm a writer by birth trade I guess
and she's a story artist and so she
brings a completely different set of
tools that helps us crack a story and
along with my producer Kelly Cooney it
made perfect sense to elevate her to a
co-director because
she had a real connection to Ruby number
one which is the most important thing
you know the emotional connection to
these your characters but then also an
incredible sense of humor and there are
things that people who came up through
Story look at things differently when
you're answering when you're trying to
solve because our day is just solving
problems um especially with original
film an original film is wonderful
because the world is wide open but it's
also hard because everything's wide open
uh so there's a lot of lanes you can go
down and you want to try them we all
want to try everything
um because we're all creative but we
have to make choices
um so it's really nice to have somebody
that compliments you and also you know
in this one having you know a female
director that could bring
um you know this was the story we were
telling bring her experience to the
movie now the perfect follow-up to that
because there's a quote from her about
you in our production notes that I love
she was talking about how your directing
style is open and collaborative yet
declarative when a hard decision had to
be made he knew exactly what to do can
you give me an example of why one of
those hard decisions and then how you
went about you know overcoming that
challenge and executing the decision you
made Ah that's wow that's really nice
thank you
um but yeah I really you know one thing
is that I always try to come knowing
that multiple imaginations working on a
movie gives it more breadth of appeal
um and the question really is is that
there's always a better idea you can
always beat the idea but there's times
where we need to for the longer Arc of
the movie or the longer sequences that
it's it's things that happen that you
have to just say that would be really
cool but that's going to send that part
too far and it's really just keeping the
spine intact and letting the artist you
know iterate and you know improv it's an
improv but we have to if we enter a
scene one way we have to get out the
other what happens during it is where
all the magic happens where the fun
happens but um so yeah I think that's
what it is it's trying to keep that that
spine what do you think is the biggest
difference between the story and how you
envision the film turning out day one
when you first signed on compared to
what we see now in the final film oh
honestly I could never have imagined and
I don't even know if they could have
imagined the level of visual uh you know
under in the water treatments and the
underwater world uh every time
we asked them and a lot came from their
story because she's a kraken and a
kraken usually ends stories they are the
most powerful creatures on the planet in
every mythology we've ever read so we
had to keep upping the challenges for
Ruby during the course of the film and
the entire second act when we would be
like well she would just get this it was
hidden behind a wall like wow that
wouldn't do anything she's a kraken so
building these challenges took all of
the Departments to come together
um and really work
um in in a in a room try to figure out
what we could do production wise but
what was best for the story and most
challenging for our lead was the uh the
choice to have your mermaid's hair red
deliberate well that was I think that
that sort of story was playing very much
into the teen comedy of the movie which
was the new girl the Mean Girls of the
sea the Regina George had to have been
that girl and it just worked so fast
when you turn when she turns her head
around and she's the new girl in and
that's the one that becomes most popular
in instant I mean it happens to align
with something else yes I was amused by
that I have one other foreign quote that
I wanted to ask you about because she
also said you have a wealth of knowledge
and references in terms of movies so now
I absolutely must know what is the movie
you know top to bottom the one you quote
the most oh wow you know I can do which
I probably won't but I when I started
Croods I at DreamWorks I was running
with John Cleese so I can do a lot of
Monty Python which I won't do right now
but I wrote two scripts with John and I
can do a lot of my favorite I don't even
know
I don't even know
and bring out the I can do some French
taunter but I did I do accent so no I'll
leave that up to and they also have
access to the internet so they can look
up the best Clips okay fair enough fair
enough so we were talking about my niece
earlier and she's first discovering
movies now and it just the thought that
she could see anything at this point
that she can look back on and think to
herself like that was the first time I
was totally enveloped by movie Magic to
the point that it made me believe
something out of this world was actually
real it's just like such a special thing
so what was that movie for you the first
time that you really recognized the
power that movie Magic and big screen
storytelling could have well I'm a Star
Wars kid and an ET kid so it's very it's
a I had some pretty I'm right in that
area of where it was and I think that
the Star Wars one ET was probably the
most surprising in the sense that I you
know we didn't know a lot about movies
walking in you know it's like so we were
kids we walked in we saw the movie I
went for I think because I liked a girl
in the class or whatever it was and we
went and we and I remember just being so
touched by it that story and then in
Star Wars I think it was the fact that
that we I play acted in my mind after
you know that was what really took me it
took me so far that the experience
um you know lasted
well multiple times we saw it at the
same time but yeah so those were the two
big ones Star Wars is a good one you're
Star Wars in that respect it's my
Jurassic Park oh yeah late in that world
more hours than I can imagine uh
Jurassic Park for me too you know I
remember exactly where I saw it in New
York and Chelsea theaters and I I know
exactly where I was who I sat with my
friend was a second ID I was a PA I sat
right there I watched that movie I know
exactly where I was